[Music]
the situation the incident was on
videotape and there wasn't a lot of
dispute as to what happened
Clark County Schools awarding a student
1.4 million dollars in Damages after she
was sexually assaulted on school
property School staff accused of being
distracted as the student was attacked
by another student inside a gym and in
the story that you will only see on
eight eight news now education reporter
Joshua peguero Joins us live in studio
Brian Denise there is a still frame of a
disturbing video that captured a student
being sexually assaulted we're not
showing the victim in this picture but
this is where the alleged assault
happened in a gym and here are five
teachers that you see on the screen
either on their cell phones or talking
with each other as the incident occurs
the video showed our client being
attacked
being thrown down on the ground and
being attacked sexually Andre Lago
marcino was one of the lawyers
representing a former student at variety
Junior Senior High School the teen is
being identified as Jane Doe to protect
her identity documents filed in civil
courts say that in March of 2020 during
PE class Jane was sexually molested she
was only 13. her lawyers go on to say
that as a result of the appalling sexual
abuse and Trauma Jane Doe has suffered
physical emotional and psychological
injuries due to the district's
negligence difficulty sleeping
difficulty with intimacy
difficulty trusting adults even giving
her a hug sometimes traumatizes her she
went through a period of years with
without even eating
variety is a school for emotionally and
mentally challenged students Lago
marcino says the child who attacked this
client was deemed a known danger by
staff and at all times needed to be
supervised but the video shows that
wasn't the case although his client
wanted to take it to trial Lago marcino
says the 1.4 million dollar settlement
was the best way for her to heal he also
hopes in the future this will not happen
again the culture at the Clark County
School District needs to change it needs
to be
a culture where the student is placed in
a safe space and
the primary objective is the students
safety personal mental and physical
now there are a lot of unknowns at this
time including whether the child was
ever arrested or charged or reached out
to the district for comment but have yet
to get a response Denise